non-binary Steve Green yes the eyes I
think it's in the eyes it's hard for me
to look at Steve Green as a smaller
person because he's such a large
individual wow did you just call him fat
well he's six four isn't he that's tall
not large bro I think that's I think
it's interchangeable no I wouldn't have
called them I would call them tall yeah
he's large offensive a little bit don't
ever call me large if I said Steve was
wide that'd be oh that's really bad
unless he was actually built wide then
I'd be like that's well he's also not a
skinny guy
you are flirting with danger you're
struggling the line partner Steve you're
fat dude
you're a fatty that's what I meant the
whole time that makes sense they forced
me to say it that makes him really sad I
don't think Steve's fat no no it no it
you said it I said he's large you know
what's a large person Bart's a large
person he wishes I'm middleweight he's
kind of wild he's wider than Steve I
didn't expect you to have so much to say
he's got a white ass dude